hi I'm should make more I play Stuart
Bell and let it snow and I'm gonna be
talking about my first which could be
very cute first incorrect rumor you read
about yourself
this Breakfast Club interview I just did
like she McMorris says he's too good to
audition
never once in that interview did I say
it was too good to audition I said that
I choose not to audition anymore because
when I audition I never get picked in as
an artist you know my soul is always
crushed and I always feel like I'm not
good enough and I didn't really want to
go into the negative side of things but
instead I focus on doing the best I can
and hopefully that attracts more
positive energy
anything else you hear is incorrect boom
first job my first job was with Tyler
Perry House of Pain was on Tyler Perry's
House of Payne first acting job my first
music video I worked on was called crank
that Batman so I'm the little kid
krumping in that music video a little
bit up on YouTube that's number two
Wow first thing you do during the
holiday season this is a PG thing right
uh-huh
wink wink boom first concert you went to
it was a Nelly concert that I barely
remember but he he gave me his headband
first singer rapper you'd want to
collaborate with on his song I actually
have to collapse with two young rappers
from Atlanta one named playboy cardi and
one named lil yachty so you're ready for
that mixtape worth the risk coming at
the end of the year
Wow first embarrassing moment on stage
or on set I guess the only embarrassing
moment I've had on set I was during dope
Chanel Iman was playing like one of the
love interest in a way and I come
outside and I'm like follow I'm looking
for her and I don't have on the shirt
and I find her in a bathroom she's like
doing drugs she throws up on me whatever
in real life they wanted me to be
completely naked and I was just like nom
it's about prepared to be completely
naked in front of 50 people so yeah
boom pres memory from the set of let it
snow I just was just it was freezing
cold like outside and I was in a trench
coat so it was all bad it was just
everybody else had on like some sort of
layers and stuff out on some chelsea
boots and the trench coat and while that
might sound warm to people like me
that's living in Atlanta or somewhere
that's usually warm when it gets a
little cold and you know putting on a
coat this is fine when you're below
freezing weather in Toronto Canada no no
no no no no you need layers and lots of
them my toes were freezing through my
boots we're talking about being outside
for 12 hours during that day I mean I
was running to the tent with the heat
okay I was running to the van with the
heat boom first album you ever bought
Chris Brown there's a self-titled album
Oh first Hollywood friend between zoe
kravitz and ASAP rocky first time
someone recognized you in public
I was with Quincy who played in dope as
well we went to Cannes Film Festival
when Bill was coming out and we got out
of a car and I remember rocky getting
out first you know Quincy gets out you
kids see everybody and I remember Quincy
and his manager were kind of wait I was
like the last to get off the car or
whatever and then I heard say it was a
lot less people was two girls and I was
just like I didn't even hear them you
ever say it and then you know I looked
around and Quincy was like there she's
gonna freak English me and I was like oh
hi it was like the the most Malcom
moment I could have first time you heard
one of your songs in public
my boys in Atlanta DJ and host a lot of
clubs and stuff so they always are the
ones supported as of right now so boom I
shout out the DJ Greg Street use the
first person to play my music on the
radio in Atlanta first song or rap you
ever wrote I pop a lot I dance I break a
house and I do my thing dance you can
test me you can test me you can test me
something
first time you realized you wanted to
pursue a music career when I saw Chris
Brown performing live me 11 that center
stage I knew I could dance like that
that wasn't you know I was already a
dancer but when I saw him live like I
was already in the front I was looking
at him and I was already impressed and
I'm like you know he's doing he's doing
these moves and he's flipping and I'm
just like I just want to meet him I ran
up to his mom backstage because he told
her happy birthday whatever I ran up
there was like my voice is gone
obviously I was just I was trying to
tell her you're gonna remember my face
remember my name remember something
about me cuz you're gonna see me you're
gonna see me this before he had those
two little boys dance I'm gonna Chris
really had a major impact on shameik
Moore as an artist and this was you guys
learning a little bit about me I hope it
was cute hit me back peace ah
you